wow that was a lot of feedback that was
a lot of feedback but very good
constructive feedback yes you know dr.
feedback we found some issues that we
knew about we found some issues that we
didn't know about you know one thing
that strikes me here though is that
maybe we went a little overboard on
producing high fidelity mocks yeah we
definitely did because we're gonna need
to change a lot of these things yeah and
you know man I spent so long getting
this little plus this little checkbox
twerk right I spent so long getting
these fabs up wait hours yeah you know I
think that you know we probably could
have dialed it back just a little bit we
probably could have gone with some wire
frames to suss out some of the the
details that we were looking at you know
particularly when we talked to Hugh and
we talked to per mo we talked to them a
little bit about fab placement things
like that um you know perhaps we could
have done that with a wider frame yeah I
think we could have and I think that
would have saved us a lot of time
because we could have gotten this
feedback faster and then not had to lose
as much work as we're going to yeah
absolutely you know one of the things we
were sweating is we were talking about
some of these mocks too is like the
color and position of some of these
things and I think that that was largely
irrelevant to the feedback that we got
ya so I think that maybe some of those
discussions could have waited until
later in the cycle they could have um
some of those things though some of the
design issues are things that came up
like we had the check box you know we
asked people to check off these these
apps and poor nemo was able to find the
the little check box here very quickly
but you just could not find that there
was something in this app for to-do
lists yeah that's right um you know I
did find it interesting too that we got
contradictory feedback in that regard
from both participants you know they
wanted to look at the home screen you
know Hugh felt strongly that he wanted
to see past events or completed events
and premium didn't feel that she
wanted to see them she really wanted to
see that be as clean and clear as
possible right um you know so i think we
probably should start annotating some of
this stuff should you know i think that
one of the things we're going to have to
do is probably dig into this screen a
little bit we're probably going to have
to add some a stronger affordance for
completion task completion and
you know it's clear that even if we had
intended for the tasks to be swipeable
here that's not intuitive let's get you
some yeah post-its notes too because I
think we're going to take a lot a lot of
notes here because we're really going to
have to focus on the next iteration here
we really need to settle in on a
specific interaction so that we can make
sure that the next round of testing we
get a really cohesive flow and that our
users really understand that clearly
right so tax completion was one thing
the other thing we talked about was
whether or not we need actually a strong
affordance here for completing tasks
right this is a heads-up display screen
mmmm so it is a heads-up display screen
we'd intended it to be sleek and not
have all of these extra things on it
yeah it's an at-a-glance type thing but
if we also you know we had decided
originally that this was going to be
sort of equally a calendar app and a
to-do app and so both of those things
should be doable from the home screen
from whatever screen we had land people
on well you know actually Hugh had some
interesting feedback there though he was
confused as whether or not this is a
calendaring app word to do app right you
know we initially set out with the the
intent of doing kind of I think a
mash-up of both yeah but he was really
confused because it didn't seem to be
any task management here there was no
what are we doing there's a lot of who
what and where but not I'm sorry who
where when but not what yeah really
missing out what aspect we are and
that's a thing that we just completely
missed in the design process you know we
we have options then you know to address
that we can either say okay we need to
re-emphasize that we need to have these
big big check boxes here mmmm so maybe
even actually this this shape here just
paste it in as the as the way of doing
it because our icon is a checkbox that
is a thing that we clearly have in the
design up here but it's not a thing we
have in the design down here or we could
do something like you know change this
icon make it just a calendaring app and
that's you know it's addressing a
different problem but it's one that
we've already addressed pretty well well
you know but the thing that we really
wanted to go after here was that strong
marriage between yeah between to do and
Callen
and so I feel like if we abandon the to
do aspects of the app then maybe we're
not holding true to the true promise of
what we intended to set out to do right
um I do like your suggestion of reusing
the app icon a little bit more he gave
us some interesting feedback that he
felt the the affordance here for the
checkbox needed to be stronger and he
missed it when he first looked on it um
pratima also had some issues with it you
know we were talking about these these
gray circles not being a strong enough
affordance for a checkbox I'm sorry so I
think that we need to really strengthen
this stuff right and we can strengthen
that by making it larger we can
strengthen that by you know making it
square because you know again I expect
radio buttons to be round and checkboxes
to be squared usually you know you know
one of the things that just came to mind
is that perhaps we can take just this
one screen and do a couple of iterations
on that one screen and give those to
some users for some very directed
feedback on those specific elements um
do they feel good about using this
checkbox as that affordance right will
they pick up on the fact that it it is a
way of completing the task right so
you're saying we can do user testing on
just iterations of a specific screen
rather than the entire flow that's right
yeah we can actually drill down on
specific features to one of the pieces
of feedback that we got was actually
talking about gesture-based support
right because we had we had one person
who said that the swiping should be more
options and we have a person who said
that swiping should be you know delete
come that's right or complete yeah so
you know I certainly think that we
should probably strive to keep our UI
here very simple so I don't know that um
her name is suggestions of revealing a
panel behind these screens is really
going to be the direction that we want
to go in but I definitely think
gesture-based support is something that
we need to investigate with a higher
fidelity prototype right and when I'm
thinking about that you know
gesture-based support week we can rely
either on what we expect users to have
already seen in other apps or we can
have an instructional thing you know we
have this this mock over here that's we
have a place that we can have
information that's just sort of an
overlay on this screen yeah I would have
that inform users about how to swipe and
how to complete
task if we wanted to I think that's
something that we're going to have to
test a little bit more too because
anecdotal evidence suggests to that some
of these splash strings the people it
prevents people from actually engaging
in the app hmm so sometimes they want a
little bit more serendipitous discovery
Ranma for instance was very willing and
very tolerant of just playing with an
app to say how it worked or as I think
he was a little bit more regimented in
his needs yeah so he wanted it to be you
know if it's a duelist app we should be
able to check things off quickly that's
right that's right and what was some of
the other feedback that we got well
first off we got some positive feedback
right we don't that leave that when we
asked people to make a new event both
both of the testers we just they went
straight to these fabs especially you
know on these two screens they just went
straight for that fab that's exactly
what we hoped for and the affordances
were clearly big enough for those you
know they're smaller than this
affordance yeah you know the one
question that did come up is maybe this
affordance is just a little bit too big
yeah because it might cover up you know
I can't see whether it's just the one
person going to this event or multiple
because one of them might be out of the
fab yeah that's right so we might
actually be having a little bit of an
issue with hiding some of the data there
but I agree that positive feedback is
really encouraging that yeah at least
users are able to pick up where the fat
is and what it does they all clearly
understood that that was event creation
yeah we also got feedback that was sort
of something that we weren't looking for
originally which is both of our testers
we had them expect to be able to click
on this and open a screen like this but
that shows current details and we
actually didn't lock that up that's true
we did not you know one of the other
things just caught my eye in our design
here is then and perhaps something that
led to Hugh's confusion if you look here
we call this thing a task if you look
here we call it a task but if you look
here in this screen we call an event
that's true actually well that's his
that's the thing that I hadn't thought
about because you know as we were
designing this we were thinking of those
is sort of the same object and thread
you know we were thinking this is a task
/ event and I guess we we don't
communicate anymore that
two things we expect we sort of had an
expert blind spot there you know you
know that definitely happened well we're
gonna have to correct or rectify that
maybe involving a tech writer in this
project would be a good idea if we have
access to one right um but that might
cost us a little bit of money so maybe
we should just keep an eye for
consistency so as another option we
might be able to you know present the
same flow with maybe all of these say
event or all this a task or some other
word that might that might communicate
all of that and just see you know is
Hugh able to figure that it is Renee
Mabel to figure that out is it anyone
else that we have in our office able to
figure that out yeah I think that's a
great suggestion not only testing some
of the UI components like for instance
where the fab was or whether or not
there's a hero but testing the language
of the app is a really important part of
I think bringing the highest fidelity to
our experience we really want that
measure of consistency through our app
for our users right all right so well
we've got a lot of feedback and we've
got a lot of things that we can iterate
on I think right now it's time to take a
quick look at this feedback and think
about what is actionable